and let's go to our second talk
uh with uh whitetech um
[Music]
who will talk about how to detect silent
failure
in ml models so
this is your stage
all right thanks a lot for the intro and
without further ado let's delve into it
tell me that you can see my screen
yes we can cool perfect
so what i'm going to talk about today is
how to detect silent failure
but before we delve into that let me do
a quick intro
so i'm voidtech one of the co-founders
of 90ml we are a very small
vc funded startup that deals with ai
monitoring
so what we try to do is basically answer
the question that's asked here
we're trying to detect silent machine
learning failure
and then address it in some way which
seems to be quite relevant to basically
almost every data scientist that right
now works in models that make it to
production
because models tend to fail a bit and
why do i have something to say about it
that might be interesting
so um i used to run a machine learning
consultancy
and we did end-to-end projects and then
at the end clients were always asking us
okay now what
uh how to make sure that this thing
still keeps on working
and we didn't really have an answer for
that so we started
kind of investigating uh what happens
with machine learning after it has been
deployed and if it fails
uh what can we do about it
also just before we delve into that uh
let me say we are hiring
so if you'd like to work in a very cool
nice remote
uh high growth startup working on core
product working on
basically machine learning for machine
learning and you are most welcome to
apply i'll
do a bit of um i'll talk about it a bit
more
later on so let's talk about how to
detect silent machine learning failures
in production so what's on the play
today first we'll just
do a quick definition of what is model
failure
uh then so basically just yeah what it
is
then we'll explain what happens when the
models fail what are the consequences of
model failure and why
this is an important thing to tackle
both from technical and business
standpoint
uh then i will talk about the causes the
reasons why machine learning can fail
and probably will fail in production
uh we're gonna follow up with detecting
machine learning failures so really the
tool set for that the machine learning
monitoring part and then
we're gonna have a very quick
engineering slide about how to
incorporate machine learning
monitoring toolset either one you built
or one that you decide to purchase
into your infrastructure so
let's start with
a running example that i'll be using
throughout the presentation
to make the the machine learning
monitoring a bit more real a bit more
grounded
so imagine that you're a data scientist
at the big bank having 30 million
clients
and the biggest product line is
long-term
loans maybe mortgage loans and
working on the core machine learning
model
that basically does create default
predictions so we take the credit scores
and the customer information and based
on that we try to predict whether
somebody's gonna default or not uh so
and that way we can approve or
disapprove a loan
uh we're gonna define the
loan default as non-payment within one
year so it's not known
immediately we need to wait one year to
release whether this person's going to
default or not
uh we need to optimize our kind some
kind of business metric
let's pick something that's typical in
in fintech in banking so we try to
just predict optimize for roi return
investment and we're going to adjust it
by some risk factor so the more risky
loans
will have lower roi even though expected
roi may be higher
and of course when we have a business
metric we want to approximate to using
some kind of technical metric
uh the one that's widely used everywhere
in data science would be a better score
and in case you forgot what it is here
is just a very quick
um very quick overview
and an equation basically what it does
is we try to weigh the true positives
and through negatives in a way that
really reflects the business problem so
let's say that people that
apply for love and then default are more
problematic that people
who would not have defaulted but we
still reject them
so we need to weigh in some way
so imagine now we have this model this
model is bringing
few billion a year but if the quality of
the model decreases by even a few
percentage point
we go from making billions to actually
losing billions and the company might go
bankrupt
this is actually not an exaggeration
that how that's how
loan applications work on big scale and
if you systematically
underestimate the risk the bank might go
bankrupt this is exactly what happened
in 2008 so we have our example
now let's talk about machine learning
failure
so machine learning failure can be
characterized by three things silent one
first of all everything looks okay the
machine learning system still outputs
predictions
it's not an obvious failure you've seen
no errors predictions are made if you
look at them and if you have a business
person look at them
look at 50 100 200 examples they will
all look reasonable
the loans that should be rejected will
be rejected the ones that are kind of on
diverge will be on the verge
and everything looks fine at first
glance and second glance
and you don't really know whether
performance is good or not because you
will see
using our example only the real label or
real ground truth
a year from now but if model fails the
performance will have degraded
significantly
which is of course a big problem so
why is it a big problem let's talk about
the consequences first of all
in basically best case scenario you will
see a decreased significant decrease in
roi
because maybe you're pricing your loans
uh too high you're
maybe rejecting too many people and
that's still
kind of good failure because you're just
losing money a bit of money
but it might get worse in a sense that
you're not only not making any money
with your machine learning model
just in the end the goal of all machine
learning models
or almost all machine learning models
but also you might start losing money
you will have unforeseen and hidden
risks here
using our example again you can have
systemic risk if model for some reason
always
approves some loans that shouldn't have
been approved and it does it in
systematic way
the company is almost guaranteed to go
bankrupt when these people start
defaulting
few years down the line all at once in
very correlated fashion
and that's not that's not it that's not
the end of it
uh we can also have problems with the
downstream failures
so imagine that marketing and customer
acquisition department
also tries to get the clients that
give the highest roi and the highest roi
at first glance would be the people that
uh you approve for risky loans but if
this risk is
not taken fully into account your
marketing and customer acquisition
channels will go for the people that
should not be given the loans at all
and it will only make the problem worse
and worse
so the consequences can be serious but
now let's look at the
the reasons behind it before we start
talking about the solutions
so the basic reason is really really
trivial uh
as your your models are trained on
static data
normally unless you use online learning
which is
right now still very rare in business so
you train the model
on training data set you test it you
validate it blah blah blah
it works good ready to be deployed you
deployed
but as time passes the environment
changes so the input data and the
patterns between the inputs and the
outputs of course will also change
and that means that your model is no
longer a good representation of the
reality
so it will stop working and fail
silently
here to have a very specific example
let's assume that the model has been
trained on all population
but now more and more young people
applied because maybe the bank created
new really nice sleek web app
or mobile app and people actually start
using this bank
and young people tend to be more risk
prone but the muslim didn't know that we
didn't model it
because there was just not enough young
people to take that into account
so machine learning model will
systematically underestimate risk and
that
is uh basically a risk for disaster
this is the kind of basic failure mode
that is the main
kind of idea why models fail in
production because things change
now let's look at the less obvious
things
one of them is that every machine
learning model as it interacts with the
environment as it interacts with the
population
actually also affects the population and
the population will affect the data that
the model ingests
imagine here that the customers
consciously change
uh what they actually say in their law
application what things they hide
uh because the model needs to be fully
uh
can be fully explained as this is the
regulatory
uh regulatory necessity
so customers will start trying to fool
the machine learning system
and in time they will succeed which
might decrease the performance of the
model another thing
kind of obvious is that we can have
stochastic shocks things just coming
from the outside that change how
customers behave how long application
process looks like
you can have a new regulation that
imposes lower down payments so people
are more encouraged to take loans and
the system was not trained on that
population our model is not used to that
so it will not take it into account and
the last thing
is that invention we expand from even
from berlin
to bavaria will have kind of different
population there are
different risk profiles people will
behave slightly differently
and the model again is not used to that
and then let's talk about last two
reasons one of them is
very long cycles that we haven't
captured in our data
one example here would be the boost and
the boom and bust cycle
which can span 20 30 40 years even and
if we take 5-10 years which is normal to
use the data from 5-10 years from now we
will not be able to capture the cyclical
nature
and as we enter new phase in the cycle
the model will not be able to
really capture the patterns that happen
during this part of the cycle
and the last thing kind of obviously is
that as our data become more noisy
because maybe there's new bugs in the
credit scoring system
will lose performance but that's kind of
a given
so we have the reasons we know what we
know what happens we know the
consequences and we know the reasons
now let's really talk about the most
important thing here which is the tool
set
of how to actually detect it so
detection of machinery
of machine learning failure is hard
because you
it's silent right and there are some
ways to
try to approximate it try to
find the potential secondary causes of
machine learning failure or secondary
symptoms
and one of them is data drift data drift
is basically
change in the data input so not the data
outputs not
what we try to predict but just changing
the distribution of data inputs
if we look at 2d example that i've shown
here
and we see that the
the data points were kind of clustered
together and still the module managed to
find a very nice
decision boundary between them but as
time passes
maybe they will really become by model
and right now you would see that the
uh decision boundary in the second image
doesn't really reflect how the model
would
create it again if it was retrained on
the new data
and it's easy to spot it it's easy to do
it manually to make sure that there's a
problem
but what if you need to work with
hundreds or even thousands of features
then
of course this is not possible to just
model it like that and look at it
visually to see if there's change in the
in the data distribution so we need some
kind of algorithmic and statistical
tools to detect that
and as the data changes it might be that
right now the model is making
predictions on new
regions in the data that it was not
trained on so it did not capture the
patterns there which might of course
cause failure
so first and simplest way to solve it
is just diffuse at this univariate
statistical tests something like common
nagorov smear enough test
our chi-square test our exact feature
test when we look at
every single feature separately we look
at the distribution previously either
during training or maybe last
month last week last day and compare it
to the current distribution
and if it is statistically different it
means that we do have data drift
and this data truth might be kind of a
symptom
of incoming uh model failure
if we want to look at it not from the
perspective of just one variable at a
time but we want to look at them
at the same time uh very nice way to do
it is to just run
a mile detection we fit our anomaly
detection algorithm something like
one class svm or isolation forest we
run it on the data where we do have the
labels and we know
what is the performance and then as the
time passes we will just see
whether there's more and more anomalies
coming and if we see more anomalies in
our current data
compared to the previous data set it's a
strong indication that
data drift is happening and again that
might
cause problems and the last most
advanced way to detect data drift
is using generative adversarial neural
networks when we train
uh the gun on our training data so it
learns how to pirate how to mimic the
training data
and then we'll use use the discriminate
discriminator part of the network
in order to basically see if the new
production data is significantly
different from the training data
that way we can really capture all
characteristics of the data set
using a neural network it's the most
advanced way and
should be the most robust and most
efficient but of course guns are very
hard to train
and they tend to get stuck in local
minima so it's easier said than done
now i'm going to walk you through a mini
example of how to do it
just when you can you know tomorrow
start working again and if you're
curious about whether there is actually
data drift currently in in my model um
what you can do
is you import one of the uh statistical
tests i mentioned you could uh
for example import comma gaurav smirnov
test
to work on continuous data you take one
feature that you're interested in
you set the default key value to 0.05
and you run the test compare for a given
feature
comparing the previous month and
distribution of the current month
distribution
and if the return the result of the test
is that
the distributions are different with
p-value below 0.05 percent
it means that the feature has drifted
very simple thing
but just something for you to try out
later on
if you want to work with um categorical
features then you need to use chi square
test for binary
categorical teachers you should normally
go for the
fischer's exact test these are just
names they
work in reasonably similar way to give
you a quick overview of how the
ks test works it takes two distributions
it looks at the cumulative distribution
and then it basically computes the
area between those two and if it's
sufficiently big it tells you that there
is drift in the data
so now let's move on to the second way
of trying to detect whether the model
has failed
and this is the concept drift concept
drive can quickly be defined
as change in the decision boundary so
again we have a 2d
example here and on the training data
our decision boundary has been
determined or maybe it was real like
that
and now if we had looked at the labels
we would actually see that the label
the decision boundary looks like this so
it's completely different
but the patterns are different the model
doesn't work anymore
and that of course strongly implies that
your model has failed
and your um
your predictions won't be as good as
they used to be
uh how do we try to really detect
concept
this is hard in itself and if we have
access to labels we can do few
simple things first one would be just to
do the correlation analysis between
inputs and the labels not the outputs
but the labels themselves
and if we see that the correlations
themselves are drifting
then it means that we have concept group
because the
the pattern between the inputs and the
outputs
has changed then another thing what we
can do a bit more advanced than just
correlations we can create a model
your normal xg boost let's say fit it on
the training data
then fit it again from scratch on last
month last week last day
and then see if the model parameters are
significantly different if they are
again we're just right now trying to see
if the mapping
between the pattern between the inputs
the outputs has changed if it had
then we have concentrated and that is
all nice but we don't really need it
that much if we have access to leverage
because then we can just measure
performance
so what can we do if there's no labels
so we don't have the ground truth
the actuals and
uh one thing we can do is we can measure
the drift in the current future
importance imagine we have our hd boost
model
and the model has certain future
importance maybe the most important
thing is the credit history
then is the current income and then
maybe location
we take that and we look at the future
importance for every
single example and then sum together
using something like shop values
in the training and then compare it in
production it might be
that because of the data drift actually
the
the features that tend to be important
for every single example in the
production will be slightly different
than the one
in the training and if we all sum them
up together and average
average them and the future importance
is going to be different and that
kind of implies that there's still
concept drift on top of just data drift
now moving on to the last part
of detecting machine learning failure uh
here we try to
directly measure performance or at least
estimate it
and the easy thing we can do is to just
measure this
and do statistics on the metrics on
things like f beta scores f1 scores
precisions rmses etc
if they change then of course our model
is failing as simple as that
and again things get interesting if the
labels are delayed or not available at
all imagine that you're doing
a document classification you will never
really have access to labels because the
machine is doing the job that the person
was supposed to do
so right now you will never see the true
label unless you actually have
a human do the same work all over again
which defeats the purpose of
of using machine learning in the first
place so what we can do then
is instead of trying to see whether the
amount is correct or not
on every single label which basically is
recreating the model
you can look at the aggregate
performance
which funnily enough is easier to do
just looking at every single example
i will not go into details now but happy
to answer questions later
uh why is that but we can estimate the
aggregate
the aggregate performance using things
like data drift concept drift
the features itself statistics put that
all in the model
and another machine learning mode built
on top of our current machine learning
use case
that takes the input data from the past
as inputs for machine learning inputs
and outputs
from the past as inputs to the model and
then as outputs
we have the aggregate performance of the
model again
from the past on our historical data
and we build this model we fit it and
then we can
estimate the performance on current data
set when we don't have the labels
it is not guaranteed to work our current
version is just a prototype
it seems to be quite robust but of
course it's it's an open question and
by some definitions it's impossible to
fully solve
and then the last thing again something
easier is to do statistics on
business kpis if we have access to
direct business kpis
uh then of course we can just look at
them and see how they change
maybe it would be the volume of
applications etc etc
and if it goes down then it's a problem
so that was how to solve it from kind of
algorithmic perspective
now let's look at the architecture uh
the engineering perspective of that
what i have here is a very simple
radically simplified
uh kind of diagram
of how a typical machine learning system
looks like
so on the left here we have a business
process
which emits some kind of data that is
taken as a model input
so your typical features right credit
score credit history
income location uh occupation things
like that for example with our running
example of
credit scoring so this is the model
input
then we have a machine learning model
that doesn't magic and then it outputs
model output obviously what we need to
do is we take those two
then you take it into your machine
learning model
sorry machine learning monitoring system
whatever it is
you take those two things you compute
data drifty compute concept
you try to estimate performance and
if we have also access to the database
to downstream data
things like business kpis things like
labels or ground truths so whether the
model has failed
sorry whether the um credits
was successful if based on has paid back
the credit or not
and maybe some other data if we can get
access to that we should also take it
into account
and the last thing if we do have access
to model itself
it will also allow us to directly see
what are the assumptions that the model
has
whether for example it's strictly our
model then if there's some new
non-linear relationship in the data we
know for a fact we don't need to check
it that the model is not capturing that
so there's a problem
if we don't have direct access to the
model we can still create a surrogate or
fake or shadow model
which should quite well approximate the
machine learning model that's there
but maybe the assumptions won't really
be the same then we take it into our
machine learning system
where we compute all these things and
then we can output it in a dashboard as
notebook instance
uh just as an api so that the downstream
service is something like maybe
training framework uh can take it
and act on the alerts it does alert that
their model performance is not
good and the reason for that is that the
data has drifted
maybe just retraining will fix it so we
take that
and then we use it later on
uh so that's basically it uh what i
wanted to share before we finish
is just few resources there is a kind of
decent ish library called psychic
multiflow
developed by guys from the data
streaming community
it only works with data streaming so
it's not it will not
work out of the box on most machine
learning use cases
but nice thing about it is that they do
have a lot of dream detection algorithms
they are a bit more advanced with simple
statistics so yeah you're welcome to
give it a try
a few of our competitors i'm just going
to go with the biggest ones
fiddler ai they're based in silicon
valley arterial based in new york
enterprise stuff and then when it comes
to interesting things
a bit more self-promotion i have a blog
on
how to get started with monitoring give
it the read if you like it
and then a few papers kind of seminal
papers about how to do
drup detection uh basically these two
guys are the biggest names when it comes
to
data drift detection uh gia games
portuguese
uh albert bife is from paris i think
so give it a go uh you'll see this
presentation later you can just click on
the links you don't have to like take
screenshots but you're welcome to
and last thing more self-promotion is
yeah we're looking to hire data
scientists and also data engineers but
mostly data scientists currently
so come work with us we are super cool
people very small startup for
people we are vc funded so we're not
gonna run out of money anytime soon
and we offer good salary we offer stock
options we are fully remote
i live in portugal uh one of my
co-founders right now
is in spain another in belgium uh
and yeah we're cool people join us
uh also feel free to you know add me on
linkedin
send me an email or anything like that
also
if you need you know machine learning
monitoring
also let me know and that's it
thanks a lot
great thank you very much
thank you nani sorry
so questions yes actually
we have one in the chat um
okay so let me read it how far does the
noise in the data
and the overfitting of the model
influence side and fader
of the models so influence is what
influences uh influence a silent fader
of the models so i would say that the
more noisy the data is the more robust
the models will be
surprisingly because robustness
basically
regularizes the model they will be much
less performant because you have noise
in the data
but that also means that they will
whatever performance they have will
generalize quite well so they will be
more robust
and the models that are really really
optimized as much as possible
and the more they overfeed the more
overfit they are the
more you are likely to experience silent
failure if something is really over fit
or is not strictly speaking over fit
compared to the validation set but
overfit
compared to reality once you deploy it
you actually see that the data is
slightly different than in production
slightly different than what you trained
it on and the money is gonna fail
so here you should also take into
account that
even injecting some noise would make
your muscle more robust
can i jump in with a question yes please
hey so just one question how
much of the costs of this uh right now
like
how how would you estimate the cost
multiplier
of a deploying and monitoring in
production
compared to of developing the system in
the first place
that's a good question i would say it's
more or less negligible compared to
development when it comes to deployment
maybe around 10 we honestly did few
calculations when you're raising money
uh how expensive monitoring is going to
be in the future
and we ended up at around 10 of the
the general of system operations so not
really compared to development but
compared to deployment and operations
you should add around 10 to make sure
it's monitored well
and everything goes fine which i think
should generate
decent roi given that if it fails it
will not only wipe
out all the value it has provided but
take a big chunk more on top of that
thank you
other questions
um i have a question man once um
so what are you focusing or
at some point you talked in one of the
slides that you said like you have a
bigger model which take the the model
input
the mobile that input the data set and
train another model on top to be able to
predict the aggregated
statistic of it
is it what you are focusing on in the
ammo is it uh
or is it yeah yeah it's actually one of
the
the core things that we are working on
right now because people really want to
know
what happens if we don't have the labels
how can we still estimate performance
and they see it as complete witchcraft
so that is something that we're trying
to solve because first of all
it seems to be needed basically everyone
speak with says like yeah if you can
solve it yeah we want it
and also it's very interesting to work
on because it's a very hard
technical problem that has not been
resolved
yeah so that's very much is our focus
uh how do you do you see the product be
i mean will that be open so like
do you have a kind of idea of how you
want to
develop it afterwards so base maybe i
was a bit
too too humble when it comes to our
state we actually have a working mvp
uh so it's ready to be deployed it's
right now
it's not open source because the code
behind it is kind of
ugly but it works it's there
and we're ready to like we're rolling
out already we're working with companies
and monitoring their models doing first
pilots so it's their early stage but not
that early we are past the concept stage
and by default this is enterprise sas
because companies are normally very wary
to give their data away
even to a you know pure product
so they prefer to keep their data inside
their cloud
and for this reason we always need to
implement an email inside their cloud
so it takes some integration some manual
work
but in the future of course we plan to
release some open source components
looking forward to that
do we have a question oh yes we have
some questions
um
[Music]
okay our question from phil if you are
working with big data don't you find
that your
significance tests show up as
significant even from the tiniest
drift that wouldn't matter in practice
uh yeah so it's all about tuning uh
interesting thing is of course if you do
it in a very naive way when you just run
a million tests some of them
of course tend to be positive so you
need to take that into account and
adjust your p-values even if you work
with simple statistics
um and when it comes to big data yeah
that's that's all about fine tuning we
want to
have as little false positives as
possible but of course still detect
all the all the cases of failure
and it's a hard problem uh but it's it's
kind of a trade-off between false
positives and false negatives
so we don't because we take that into
account but if you approach in a very
naive way
you would indeed get alerts all the time
make sense uh
question from now what kind of clients
are you serving at the moment yeah
uh so we work right now we're switching
mostly to work with fast-growing
startups
but we also have two
uh two enterprise clients that we're
working with
mostly fintech but also one media
company
that working with either big enterprises
or startups
the reason for that is startups are very
easy to work with and they have very
interesting problems and we can also get
kind of you know validation that the
problem is real
and enterprises are very interesting
just to see how we can potentially
deploy it and enterprise because this is
not an easy thing to do
also another question from demo do you
look at fairness of the models
not sure if you can yeah uh
we can't possibly it's on our roadmap we
want to start with bias first
instead of going you know just simple
bias detection and data especially
changing bias if there was somebody that
was taken into account
and now new type of bias appears in the
data because maybe you know
marketing targets mostly males or mostly
old people
and there is new kind of bias in your
population
you will be able to actually detect it
automatically right now just looking at
the feature distribution but it changes
and on our roadmap is to address it
specifically but
it's not there yet
great
thank you uh do we get some other
question
at the moment please feel free to ask
that's the time
where okay where are
so you have you are in portugal one is
in spain
where are the two others in belgium so
our we are legally incorporated in
belgium
but yeah we are fully remote as long as
you are free to travel
here within the european union it's all
good
great so if another question i propose
to
stop here so thank you again a really
interesting presentation